right do you guys think that sex is a
need that men can't live without
um definitely I think man used to answer
that I think met yeah sex is a need that
men can't live without it depends on
what you mean though like what's the
time periods without sex and they just
living on corn I think if you what do
you think would happen if there wasn't
corn I think I think society would be
very violent wouldn't it I think if you
get a lot of men are you see an animal
kingdom isn't it it's the same sort of
thing isn't it you get you know one
alpha male that's got the females the
others are always fighting them for
positions yeah they're willing to fight
to the death I think you'd get quite a
violent society and that's one of the
reasons why monogamy came about was to
stop that because if you have men that
are not having sex and they're not
getting that frustration I guess out
they're gonna take out on society I
think if you took away corn away from
men I think men's mental health would
suffer from endlessly probably more so
than women is corn a net positive or A
negative it depends on how you I think
it can be a negative because it creates
it creates lack of false like a fantasy
and so when you know you do go out with
guys they might be like they might be
more forward with sex or certain things
because they've seen certain things they
might have that expectation so I feel
like sometimes it can be quite
pressuring and it can I think sometimes
as well that
corn is
sometimes like devaluing women I don't
know like it's kind of yeah it doesn't
it doesn't make sex feel special yeah I
don't think it makes it more like you
were saying earlier like the intimacy it
just creates a fancy sometimes
I I could see where corn is a net
negative for guys in an individual level
but
I'm just going to play devil's advocate
here I also think it's helped a lot of
guys stay faithful and sexless man I was
gonna say that I was gonna say that yeah
so
it's so true I think there's a place for
it because imagine you're one of these
guys and your wife is like a kid or two
kids whatever she's just dealing with
life and I personally am a believer in
marriage I mean we're getting married
soon right I believe in marriage right I
believe if that can keep you going
through that period it's better to
engage in that than to actually cheat
yeah and you're going to risk a hell of
a lot and I think corn from that point
of view is good but I think too much of
it right like anything where guys don't
want to go out and do anything because
they're so yeah they're addicted to it
it stops them being about their purpose
they've got these unrealistic views of
women and for some men especially men
that are more prone to that it might
make them even more violent because they
go and demand it of women and some men
do it by force I mean most sexual
assault is men are the perpetrators of
it and I think how much is corn to blame
for that you know and I think it's tap
into some ancient biological questions
increases sexual assault I think it I I
don't see why it would not because if
men are frustrated at home and all they
know is just being online at some point
you might want the real thing I think I
would think it would do I don't know but
I would think it would do the opposite
because like it gives them
the release instead of going but you've
seen some issues where men have actually
assaulted women where they've had this
addiction and they want to play out in
real life you see that often you know
there's a fantasy and they want to play
it in real life and they go by the point
I haven't seen what it is was there
something in the news or I've never seen
that wasn't that policeman actually got
done for that addicted to that the one
that um Sarah Edward I also had that I
think yeah yeah so what happened porn
addiction did he not would the one that
actually drag the woman off the streets
and Clapham I think he had an addiction
sorry I'm recording because um you know
and it's natural isn't it if that's all
you know is the virtual version of
something at some point it's quite easy
to spill over into watching the real
version it's the same thing with video
games like men that play video games are
going to be more violent because I'm
pretty sure the evidence was the
opposite with that I definitely don't
believe it again I agree with I I think
that is true as well because for example
I don't know about not really in the UK
but I heard about a lot school shootings
with like young people in America like
it's always to do with guns and always
to do with yeah like those kind of like
video games so I think that definitely
has an impact as well but then that's
like
everything has an impact with social
media and with technology because even
what we see online might change the way
that we move or we look so everything
does I think but I think it's only going
to amplify what's already there it's
already there yeah so if you're someone
that's that way inclined then yeah it
might imply but I think for most people
playing video games is a way to safely
indulge in your fantasies yeah exactly
with corn like you know same thing like
that statistic you you stated it's
almost one in three guys so it's getting
like really high and I think it's it's
like still upward trending right so who
knows where that's going to end but when
a guy can just you know against safely
like go watch corn and deal with that
desire and not have to put himself out
there not get his ego bruise or not face
you know potential legal consequences or
anything like that plus most guys have
no idea what what to do anyways right
and what I've noticed with so many of my
clients is guys genuinely will put in
time and effort in some cases money with
a lot of these companies that are
supposed to help them and they still
fail and then they're like Oh what now
like rewire your brain chemistry or
something though
like I just don't feel I don't see a
world where it is a good thing I can't
lie I don't it's not do or die you will
you will survive without a ticket I
don't think it's a good thing but I I
wonder if man like the bad because they
say that in societies that um
have a large group of sexless men those
men become violent and so I wonder if
corn helps deter men from being violent
because then they have access to
sexuality in a way these these men they
need good that's what they need Amen to
that I think that's what they need I
think it just
I don't know I just feel like the way
that sex is now is not the same like
people
it's just not like maybe that's what we
love having it intimacy it's just not
about that it's just about getting your
nut in like well that's why my question
was does sucks a need that men can't
live without
because there's some men like I I call I
have a great Granddad here and he he
didn't have no kids no he had a partner
for a while but then he went to the war
and he just traveled around the world
and that was his Focus that was his
purpose so I think sometimes they can
shift their purpose I don't yeah I think
maybe some men are capable a lot more
restraint when it comes
it's just that people don't have the
mental toughness anymore it's like
everything's easy so you can it doesn't
have the mental toughness men or women
are one in three women under 30 virgins
I think no both genders don't have the
mental toughness anymore right now uh
what were you gonna say I was gonna say
with your um scenario with your granddad
that could just be like oh is that out
of choice or is it not out of choice do
you know what I mean don't say a joke
though I actually kind of like yeah do
you know that that Tick Tock one is like
um
I really I I I need to
I need to think about it before
are you sure it's straight that's what I
want to say he's definitely straight but
he's like but he was all into like the
um like Wildlife going for Wars you were
just out here
but maybe that's his age because he was
like in 90 something I don't know it was
the end but I think he wasn't focused on
that men can't ultimately be fulfilled
like I don't need to live without it I
mean it sounds like you know with the
guy kill himself or something like that
but yeah I don't think they cannot
ultimately be fulfilled because I've had
lots of clients where they have every
area of Life handled I'm sure you've
seen this a lot of times if they don't
have the girl that's like life isn't
complete they're not fulfilled they're
not ultimately happy even if they've got
the money the body like everything they
could have everything going on but
without that partner by their side
they're not ultimately he had a
companion for years but he never like it
wasn't that kind of relationship it was
just like a companion so I think that
can be fulfilled with with that
loneliness not necessarily like a sexual
drive that can just be yeah men are not
emotional you think about it
so they can they I don't think they
can't go without sex but they don't need
that romance they don't need that
affection they don't need like we do so
if they want to do whatever they're
doing in the bedroom watching whatever
they want to watch about then they're
happy with it I think I think foreigners
are really well actually I think it's
kind of healthy because I believe like
all men they need so yeah yeah I agree I
think that they need you know and like
it's good that they at least have corn
you know at least they have that thing
that's like oh cool and it's like what
he does in private at least like oh he
really is I think it's
something natural I think it shouldn't
be like something that you have to be
banned or oh look what these girls are
doing here like okay they chose to do
that they should still work like that so
that's their problems you know don't
look down on that yeah but they're like
um oh because there's type of corn
that's like this there's type of corn
that's like that
they have all the Styles because they
have like a public for all these types
otherwise they wouldn't exist yeah so I
think it's like it's like a necessity
for them but imagine going on your
partner's phone right wow wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait hear me
out here we are cool imagine going on
okay imagine going on your partner's
phone and seeing that they search for a
certain thing so it could be and it's
not me
is that an issue for you women
[Laughter]
yes raise your hand no no
yes yeah you guys say yes
what if what if um so if you think corn
is cheating if you say no to him for sex
can he then go do corn nah yeah but
that's not with me but
can he go and just yeah but can he go
and just sleep with anyone else you'd
rather him sleep with someone else I
don't rather him it's it's I'd rather
not know about it and do whatever you
want to do if you're going to sleep with
someone that person you I'd rather you
pay that person and you never cheat on
someone that I personally know so I can
just like at least get to that situation
but I'd rather not know so is it
cheating
but that's why I just it's so
complicated it's not that easy that's
why I really don't want to know are you
okay with that in your relationship what
like cheating as long as you don't as
long as you don't know no
my partner was okay with it I'd almost
look at you less yeah yes as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible